on the mound for the padres their ace
you darvish 34 year old making his 15th
start the opponent's only hitting
196 off of you darvish nine home runs
84 innings and the 97 strikeout three
shy of a hundo for the right-hander
1-0 sharply hit and picked on the half
hop by machado the throw is good and
betts is out number one
good pick down there at third base on
the half hop by manny well what danny
manny does so well keeping the glove
down right there on that hot smash
possibly possibly taking away extra
bases that ball hooking
he did position himself perfectly in
front of it the short hop
and the nice easy throw over to
kronoworth
swinging a miss and darby strikes out
turner first k of the night for you
darvish
strikes out smith back-to-back case for
darvish
dodgers don't score podraiser coming up
julio urias
on the mound for the la dodgers he's
faced the padres nine times in his
career three of those starts he's got a
one
six nine era against him that includes
one unearned run over five innings to
get the win in the clinch and game of
the division series last year
down the right field line mckinstry is
not going to get there it's over his
head one up
the wall fam headed for two at least and
he'll pull it up
at second base in the lead off double
there we go two on nobody
out and jay cronenworth to bat for the
first time tonight
lying to the left center field that's
going to get in for a hit
here comes tommy pham he'll score we're
going to stop fernando at third it's an
rbi double for cronenworth and it's the
padres who strike first
second and third nobody out in this
padres first inning and it's time for
manny machado
machado to left field rex going back
at the wall man oh man oh man
it's a three-run home run padres take a
four-nothing lead
before there's an out in the first
inning
look at manny get to it get the hands in
stay down on it
extension let it fly
tatis junior knows it well there are
fast starts and then there is this
spin it wear it proudly ha
kim did you notice he's going double
oven mitt over there at first base
why not i'd protect all my fingers matt
leads it off here for the dodgers great
first inning for the padres
swinging a mess that's three strikeouts
in a row for you darvish
[Applause]
swinging a mess taylor strikes out
that's four k's in a row for you darvish
zach mckinstry standing in for la
they struck him out matt beatty chris
taylor
zach mckinstry all down by way of the k
his payoff breaks through the back door
to give him his first strikeout
there is gets him with a good change out
back-to-back caves
open the second there's a slurp to
right-handers he wants to look like a
ball end up a strike the change-up he
wants to look like a strike
end up a ball and that's what he does
perfectly here
jack rex stands in for his major league
debut
swing and a miss and rex strikes out
that is
six straight strikeouts for you darvish
not an easy way to
break big league seal strikes him out
how about seven straight strikeouts for
you darvish two down in the third inning
with seven consecutive strikeouts
tonight
ties the second most in padres history
second time through the lineup mookie
betts
it's a fly ball to straight away
jumping on the first pitch to get the
dodgers on the board in the third
first hit of the game for the dodgers
produces their first run it's 4-1
[Music]
[Applause]
on that exchange and they went 643 to
wipe them clear and finish the inning
four to one padres have the lead over
the dodgers it's to the fourth we go
swinging a miss and he struck him out
went to the slider together
eight strikeouts for you darvish
by him back-to-back strikeouts nine and
all for you darvish two down in the
fourth inning
beatty lines it to right and machado
back to make the play in the shift
little leap there at the end to reel it
in in the perfect spot
baker mayfield in the house cleveland
browns quarterback
taking in a padres game chris taylor
struck him out making 10 for you darvish
46th a double-digit strikeout game for
you darvish in his career and they stack
it up
in a shift tatis rips it to left
wrecks a player off the wall fernando's
into second base of the leadoff double
good start to the bottom of the fifth
for the padres
ah the tough twist after the double
this kid is a rock star there's jay
chronoworth
high drive deep right field we are all
in the ground zone
two run shot for jake connor worth
padres take a 6-1 lead jake cronenworth
with a two-run homer
his ninth of the year san diego
is rocking
that'll eat up turner at third and get
into left field machado with a wide turn
at first he'll throw the brakes on
the board for the second time in this
game
taking off is machado myers will take a
pitch high
and man he's got to stole the base stay
on that bag i think he did
well chalk up another stolen base for
the padres they are first in major
league baseball they lead the world
that's number 69 for the friars
and manny does stay on the back you
darvish returns to the mound here for
the
sixth inning that is strike three
make it the 15th hundredth strikeout for
you darvish
rogers making noise really for the first
time in this game
one hopper knocked down by kim stays
with it and makes the play
out of the jam is you darvish six to one
the padres have the lead they're working
on hassan kim
who appeared to take that exploding
ground ball off the finger
and was in some pain see if he stays in
this game
headed to the clubhouse right now it
appears
fly ball center field grisham
makes the catch and out of the jam is
austin adams
dodgers leave him loaded 6-1 san diego
up comes will smith looking for his
first hit of the night
on a 2-0 smith hits one in the air to
left center field
forget about it homerun will smith
into the second deck his fourth in his
last nine games
and it's 6-2 two down to the ninth aj
pollock
down from third comes machado caratini's
over but this is manny's play
padres take game one of the series